[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
58 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm very sleepy.
You got me up very
early this morning,
because you're in Europe.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know.
I am in these beautiful
place called [INAUDIBLE]
near Barcelona,
working from home.
And yeah, it's
like 4:20 PM here,
so it's like 7:00
AM in San Francisco.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
You got me up super early.
So thanks for that.
I love you.
Thank you so much.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I'm not even sorry.
I'm actually not even
sorry about that,
I'm sorry about the topic
of the podcast today.
MARK MANDEL: You're not sorry.
I mean so today's topic is
where Francesc spontaneously
combusts, because we're
talking about Java.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yay.
MARK MANDEL: But we have
a wonderful conversation
about Java, and Java on GCP,
with Ray Tsang and Rajeev
Dayal.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: You may recognize
Ray from previous episodes,
as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, such
as many others, actually.
I think that he did one with--
the one I can remember is the
one about Google Cloud Spin.
Yeah, Google Cloud Spin.
That was fun.
But I think he's also
been to another one.
I do not remember now.
MARK MANDEL: That's all right.
And then at the end, we're
going to have a discussion
about moving data between
cloud providers-- specifically,
if you need to move data
from S3 to cloud storage,
is there any easy
way to do that?
But before we do
that, why don't we get
stuck into our cool
things of the week.
Francesc I know
you found a bunch
of really interesting ones.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
There's actually two of them
that I'm very excited about,
because there are things that
I'm actually going to do.
The first one is a
tenser flow course.
It's a crash course on
deploying with TensorFlow.
It's three hours long.
And it doesn't require a PhD.
That's what they say.
So I'm pretty excited,
because I do not have one.
MARK MANDEL: I do not
have a PhD, either.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, so I'm very
excited about going through,
learning a little bit more
about all the details
of TensorFlow,
and how to actually use it
for something specific-- like
try to build something with it.
I've been thinking
about it for a while,
and I think that that's a
perfect opportunity to try it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It looks like it's
a video course.
Is that right?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It's actually a video of course.
It's, as I said,
a bunch of hours.
But it's definitely worth it.
It's done by Martin Gorner, one
of our teammates-- a developer
advocate for Google
Cloud platform in Paris.
MARK MANDEL: Very, very cool.
So speaking of teammates, one
of our other developer advocate
teammates--
Amy Gdala as she is on Twitter--
has written a blog post
about combining Cloud ML
natural language API and
running a Slackbot, and how they
can be integrated together.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It is really cool, because--
there's two things.
I mean, there's bots.
And everybody likes
bots, of course.
MARK MANDEL: Of course.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But also,
there is all the parts
about Cloud ML--
the natural language
API-- is super powerful.
I don't know if you have
played a little bit with it.
MARK MANDEL: A little bit.
A little bit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
One of my favorite
things is that it
does entity recognition,
which is basically
you can say things like New
York, and it was like, yeah,
New York.
But you can also
say the Big Apple,
and it will say, yeah, New York.
So it's actually
able to understand
all these complex concepts
and tie them together,
which is very nice.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
what I thought
was quite interesting
about this, too,
is it does sentiment
analysis in terms of like,
are these positive comments
or negative comments?
And it can respond.
But you can also do like
topped entity listings.
So you can start to see what
the topics of conversation
across time have been within the
Slack channel, which I think is
actually really, really cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Yeah, I will not get into the
details on the Slack channel
where she's talking,
because it seems
like it's related to politics,
which I try to avoid lately.
Anyway, I think we have one more
cool thing of the week, though.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So we talked about
this a little bit
last week, where we were talking
about Cloud audit logging,
so that you can determine
like who does what, and where,
and when, and how on the
Google Cloud platform.
But literally last week, when
we announced the podcast,
at the same time
there was a blog
put out explaining that we have
a significantly expanded set
of products that Cloud audit
logging is now integrated with,
which is really cool.
So its now works with Compute
Engine, Container Engine,
Dataproc, Deployment Manager,
Cloud DNS, Key Management
Service, Cloud
Storage, and Cloud SQL.
The above integrations
are all in beta,
but it does work
across the board.
So its pretty sweet.
And the article
goes through how you
can interact with the audit
logs in cloud console,
how you can interact with
them and Stackdriver,
you can do alerts-- and
it even talks about,
if you're signed up for the
alpha for Cloud Functions, how
you can also use cloud functions
to interact with your audit
trails, as well.
So you can have automatic
responses to certain actions
that people take within
your Google Cloud Platform
project, which I think
is pretty cool as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So yeah, I think that
is important to remind
our listeners, just in case
you were wondering what
is the difference between Cloud
Audit logging and Google Cloud
IAM.
Because sometimes it may
be a little bit confusing.
The way I like to put it is--
Cloud IAM says who's
allowed to do what,
and Cloud Audit logging
says who did what.
So it's not if you're
allowed or not.
It's like, did you
actually do it?
So it's good for logging.
Like if you have
something that people
are allowed to do but you want
to make sure they didn't do it
too often, or that they have
a reason behind it to do it,
that is the product to use.
MARK MANDEL: Mm-hmm.
Sounds good.
All right, well, I
think that's probably
enough for cool
things of the week.
I'm sure we could
go on for a while.
But why don't we go have a
chat with Ray and Rajeev,
and talk about Java.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I don't want to.
No, it's OK.
Let's do that.
MARK MANDEL: That sounds good.
Today we are joined
by a teammate,
and also by an
engineering manager.
We are joined today by Ray
Tsang and Rajeev Dayal.
Ray, how are you doing today?
RAY TSANG: Pretty good.
How are you?
MARK MANDEL: Good.
And Rajeev, how are you doing?
RAJEEV DAYAL: I'm well.
I'm well, thank you for asking.
MARK MANDEL:
Excellent, excellent.
So before we get stuck
into all the good things,
why don't you tell us a
little bit about yourself.
Rajeev, why don't you go first?
RAJEEV DAYAL: So I'm Rajeev, and
I'm an engineering manager here
at Google.
I've been at Google for
about 10 years or so--
so quite a while.
And right now I'm managing
teams that work on the Cloud SDK
and Java on Google's
Cloud platform.
So I'm really focused on
Cloud developer tools.
Before that, I used to work on
the Google Web Toolkit, or GWT,
as it's now called.
So yeah, some of you
may remember that.
MARK MANDEL: I remember that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I used to use
that a long time ago, yeah.
That is cool.
What about you Ray?
Why don't you tell us a
little bit about what you do?
RAY TSANG: Sure.
So I'm a developer advocate.
I'm based in New York.
And I focus a lot on the
Java communities and Java
developers, and making sure
that the experiences with Google
Cloud Platform is the best
for the community as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
if I'm not mistaken,
it's your second
episode with us?
RAY TSANG: That's right.
Yes.
This is my second episode.
Thanks for having me back,
given that the last episode
I don't know how well we did.
I'm sorry.
MARK MANDEL: It was awful.
RAY TSANG: Oh thank you.
MARK MANDEL: No, I
was just kidding.
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
But it was the
Cloud Spin episode,
which I had a lot of fun with.
So I'm happy to be back again.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Also, we're
very happy that you're back.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
All right, so we are having
an episode about Java.
We have talked about
some other languages,
so we figured it's good to
come around to Java as well.
So I guess I will ask
Rajeev, you know, why Java?
Why is Java important to GCP?
What's the story there?
RAJEEV DAYAL: Well, Java--
you know, it's an
important language.
It's been, I guess, really
since like the mid '90s.
And then, since then it's
just become pretty much
a staple language that's
used everywhere, honestly.
It's used very
heavily in enterprise.
I think the language index--
the TIOBE index-- still
shows Java as the most heavily
used language across the board
for all sorts of applications.
So yeah, it's just a
hugely important language.
I think one of the reasons
for that is because it's just
pretty versatile as well.
It's one of those languages.
Some people say like, oh, you
know which is more expressive,
or it's too verbose.
And some of those
things may be true.
But it's also shown
that you can build
like really large applications
and services with it.
You can have like
really big code bases,
and they're still maintainable.
So it's really important that
we support Java developers
and such workloads on GCP,
especially as more enterprises
are moving into the Cloud.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I know that one
of the places where
we talk about Java all the time
on the cloud is App Engine.
RAJEEV DAYAL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But
what other things
are there in Google
Cloud Platform
that are related to Java?
And what is the
best place to run
Java on Google Cloud Platform?
RAJEEV DAYAL: So I'll
take a stab at this,
and then Ray can jump in.
I think it really depends
on what you're doing, right?
So App Engine standard
actually is like a good place
to run Java if you really
care about very sort
of spiky traffic-- very
fast, sort of like scale up
and scale down.
You want to have
reactiveness to that.
And you're OK with sort of
being a little more constrained
in what you do, because
you want the auto
scaling to work for you.
So that's a very good
environment for Java, actually,
because you don't have to
think about the scaling.
If you're working
with containers,
you know Kubernetes, and
then running it on GKE
is obviously a great
environment for that.
This is basically
hosted Kubernetes.
So there you kind of
have more control.
You're working with
containers and Kubernetes.
Especially if you're sort of
breaking your application up
into microservices, you can
handle like pretty heavy
traffic and whatnot.
You can kind of do
what you want there.
And then of course you've got
Google Compute Engine, or GCE.
And that's just a raw VM.
So obviously, you
can do what you want.
It's just that all the
set up is up to you.
So there's lots of
different places
to run Java workloads on
Google's Cloud Platform.
It really depends on
what you want to do.
MARK MANDEL: And I
believe you can also
run Java on some of
our big data stuff
as well, like Dataflow
and some other tools.
RAJEEV DAYAL: Yeah.
That's correct, actually.
That's correct.
Actually, the data flow
SDK is actually Java.
And so, yeah, that's
also really popular.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Ray, I know there are some other
places where Java is supported,
not just to be able
to just run your code,
but other things like that--
so like tooling and
SDKs and IDEs and stuff.
Ray, you want to talk a
little bit about that?
RAY TSANG: Sure.
Actually, Rajeev and another
engineer-- a team lead here,
who's not here today on
the podcast, but Patrick--
they actually developed
all the tunings for Java.
So we have really
good tooling support
for if you are into
building tools.
So for Maven and greater,
we have plugins for those.
For the IDEs, we also
have IDE integrations
with Eclipse and InelliJ.
So the idea, there, is for you
to be able to start a project
and develop your applications,
and be able to deploy into some
of those environments
that Rajeev just
mentioned, seamlessly,
directly from the IDE.
But also, if you need
to integrate with say
a CICD platform of some sort,
or manage your own deployment,
you can also do that
from the command line--
from your plugins as well
as from the build tools.
RAJEEV DAYAL: And
yeah, just adding
on to that a little bit--
we've had, in the past, plugins
for Eclipse-- like the Google
plugin for Eclipse, which has
been there for a long time
and is being used to
support GWT and actually
App Engine for a long time.
And we've invested
back in that, and we're
building new Eclipse tooling
that is purely Cloud focused,
actually.
So we're putting a lot more
investment into Eclipse.
And we'll expand that
functionality as well,
to handle things like Dataflow--
to make it a lot easier to work
with Dataflow.
There already is a plugin
for Eclipse for Dataflow.
We'll integrate
those two together,
so it will be in one package.
MARK MANDEL: So I've
also been seeing
a lot of activity on the
IntelliJ plug-in as well.
Can you talk a little
bit about that as well?
RAJEEV DAYAL: Yeah.
Actually, so that whole thing
started with Android Studio.
So Android Studio
was released in--
I think it was like 2013.
And it is built on
the IntelliJ Platform,
as I think most people know now.
And actually, we did
Cloud integration in there
like a while back, actually.
And the idea back then was like
create an App Engine back end,
and use Cloud Endpoints
to wire that up
to your mobile application,
with the thought being
that, OK, you just want a
simple back end and a way
to talk to it with REST.
Now we have other solutions,
like Firebase, which
are better suited to that.
But that's kind of
what we started with.
And then what we did was we
basically spun that back out
and improved it into an IntelliJ
plugin for community edition
and ultimate, to be
able to just like--
if you're just a Cloud
developer-- to be
able to work with App Engine.
And that's going
to be our basis,
and we're going to
expand upon that
and build more GCB
features into that plug-in.
And, you know, it's timely.
Because IntelliJ's popularity
has really taken off
in the past two or three years.
So we really need to have
a good story in both IDEs,
because the community is
split across both of them.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I
use IntelliJ a lot.
I don't actually
write in Java in it.
I use it for everything else.
RAJEEV DAYAL: Yeah.
I'd be like that too, right?
MARK MANDEL: But I'm a huge fan.
It's pretty good for
almost every language
that it supports.
They're very good.
Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So, since we're talking
about other languages,
what about the other
languages that run on the JVM?
We've been talking
about mainly about Java.
But what if I have
a Scala application?
Can I run Scala on--
I mean, of course I can run
it on Google Compute Engine.
But can I run it
also on App Engine?
RAY TSANG: Yeah, I
can take a stab at it.
So, for example,
with App Engine Flex,
you can basically run
whatever you want.
So it's not limited to just pure
Java or any certain languages
that this supports.
But if you really want to
you, can definitely just
write it in whatever languages
you wish to write in, including
any of the other JVM
languages-- and just
being able to package it up
properly, or even just package
it up into a docker container.
And as long as you're
listening to the right ports,
and responding to the right
health check endpoints,
we will be able to serve
those applications directly
in App Engine
Flexible as a pass.
Now, of course if you
have the container,
you can also always just run
it in Google Container Engine,
if you need fine control
over your application.
So you could do it either way.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: What
about on standard?
Is it a but hacky?
I have to ask.
I'm curious.
RAY TSANG: Ha, ha, ha.
MARK MANDEL: If I want
to take my Closure app
and run it on App Engine
Standard, can I do that?
RAY TSANG: Now, it depends.
So does Closure app--
can you actually package
it into a WAR file?
Because you need to
be able to deploy that
into Tomcat or sort of a
Jetty container at the moment.
So for example, you cannot--
at the moment--
run any of the JAR
files if you have a
self-executable JAR.
But if you can
package up your app
in standard Jetty
container in a WAR file,
then you may be able to run it.
You should give it a try, Mark.
RAJEEV DAYAL: Yeah.
I bet you if you--
MARK MANDEL: I'll
take it for a spin.
RAJEEV DAYAL: --if
you do enough hackery,
there's probably some way
to get it going, right?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I bet you there is some
way to get it going.
RAJEEV DAYAL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And could you share
if there's any actual
plans on doing more
about these languages?
Like, for instance, we recently
had someone new in our team--
Guillaume Laforge.
He created Groovy.
What about Groovy--
on App Engine Standard
I'm talking about?
RAJEEV DAYAL: So that's a
good question, actually.
I think there isn't anything
directly in the pipeline
that I know about
to support that.
But I do know
they're working to--
this sounds kind of weird-- to
make the App Engine Standard
environment slightly
more flexible, you know,
so that you could
basically have less--
you're still running Java.
You're kind of in a JVM, but
there's fewer restrictions.
So in a world like
that, I could see
more of that being possible.
But I couldn't concretely
say, yet, honestly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: That's fair.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
I have a question.
As some of you may know, I
don't write Java that often.
I'm more of a Go person.
I know, it's shocking.
RAJEEV DAYAL: That's OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
(LAUGHING) That's OK.
One of the things
that I've heard about
is that, when you create
microservices in Java,
it's not really a microservice
because the JVM is so big.
Is that actually a problem?
I'm sincerely
asking the question.
For instance, if
you have on GKE,
is a container
going to take longer
to start because of
the JVM being large?
Or is there any of
those issues that people
that are writing Java
should take into account?
RAJEEV DAYAL: So as far as
microservice is concerned,
the actual code that
you write in Java--
given the recent
framework developments,
like Spring Boot and
many, many others--
you actually write very
few codes to achieve a lot,
because of all the common tasks
that these frameworks will be
able to take care of for you.
And so the code that you
write is actually quite small.
You can really focus
on the business problem
that you need to solve.
In the end, the package--
the actual binary file that you
compile-- is also very small.
So the JVM is really
there to support
the runtime environment.
Now, with docker
containers, of course,
there's the concept of layering.
So you can layer that JVM
image underneath of your app,
so that you don't have to, say,
redeploy hundreds of megabytes
of JVM every single time.
So the actual app
that you deploy
could be as small as the code
that actually just changed.
And that is a powerful
concept, because now
that will then give you a very
rapid deployment across all
the services that you have.
You don't have to really
manage which version of JVM
should be running,
because all of that
will be encapsulated in
one of the image layers
that you depend on.
And the startup time
is actually quite fast.
I mean, these apps can start
in seconds, to be honest.
So that shouldn't
be much of an issue.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Nice segue, I think.
You mentioned Spring there.
I know we've also talked about
Jetty in a couple of things.
If I'm a Java developer, and
I'm going back to a while
when I used to live
a lot in the JVM,
are there are particular
frameworks, or--
as you were talking
about Jetty-- things
like basically
runtime environments,
I guess, that are better
supported than others?
So if I'm coming to GCP, and
I'm going to write a Java app,
should I be looking at
particular frameworks
or particular runtimes
to get my app running
so I can run it on the web?
Does that make sense?
RAY TSANG: So at the
very basic level,
there's the GAE standards
with the servlet.
So that's definitely
supported, right?
So even today, I mean, since
the App Engine standard,
GAE spec has been
supported in a way.
So you can write a servlet.
You can serve your JSPs--
very standard Java stuff.
In Flex, you can run even
more, basically removing
some of the traditional
App Engine standard sandbox
restrictions.
You can run basically whatever
framework that you want to run.
But Rajeev, do you
want to add to that?
RAJEEV DAYAL: Yeah.
So I think you covered it well.
I guess what I would add is--
there is a bunch of work
that is in progress--
so it isn't there yet--
to integrate more of these
frameworks in with GCP.
So for example,
in Spring, there's
things like Spring Cloud Stream.
And we want to integrate that
in with our Cloud Pub/Sub,
so that you have a
nice integration there.
You could wire it up
yourself, if you wanted to.
But that's obviously
a bunch of work.
And we want to have something
like that ready for you when
you come to the platform.
Another example is-- so we have
the Stackdriver diagnostics
platform.
That's part of GCP.
So you know this gives you
information on your application
as it runs.
You have stats.
You see like traces and whatnot.
And you see like logging,
error reporting--
we want to wire that into what
Spring also has in that vein,
like Spring Actuator
and whatnot, as well.
So basically you can
get that for free,
as opposed to having to wire
all of that up yourself.
So these are integrations
that we're currently
working on right now.
They don't exist yet.
But we want to make it a
much better experience when
you come to our
platform with Spring,
and you just get a
lot more for free.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Since we're talking about
stuff that's coming,
is there anything else you
want to talk about that
might be in the pipeline
that Java developers might
be excited about?
RAY TSANG: So one thing
that I want to mention
is something that actually
just came out, I think,
before the new year.
It is our ZipKin connectors.
So if anyone is interested
in developing microservices
in general, you might need
to be able to trace the calls
across multiple services.
And in the Java world, a
lot of it is using ZipKin,
and you can tie it up with
Spring Boot if you want to.
So rather than maintaining,
say, your own ZipKin server,
there is actually
a proxy, now, that
can take in ZipKin
requests for the tracing,
and then it can forward the
trace information directly
into Cloud Stackdriver Trace.
So what that means is you
have less to maintain,
and you don't have to
change your code in order
to be able to trace
your applications.
You can browse all the
trace information directly
from the GCP console.
RAJEEV DAYAL:
Another cool thing--
it isn't super new, but I
don't know how well known
it is-- is the Cloud
Debugger, actually.
So this is a pretty cool
piece of technology.
It's actually what
you might call
like a post-mortem debugger,
or it's a production debugger.
So when you set a breakpoint,
you're not actually
stopping execution.
What you're actually doing
is you're saying that,
OK, you want to take a sample or
trace of some of the requests--
sort of a snapshot of the
stack at that point in time--
so that you can come back later.
And you can sort
of view-- like, OK,
when I hit this when I
hit this breakpoint, what
was going on at this time?
And this is pretty cool,
because normally you
can't use this type of feature
in production-- because you
would halt execution, and then
no one can go to your site.
And that's no good, right?
But what we've done
here is now you can even
set conditional breakpoints.
So like, on a certain
condition you trip this.
And then you can be like,
oh, what happened here?
This was hit.
Why was it hit?
Let me walk through.
And we've actually wired
integration into IntelliJ.
So you can actually
walk through this stack
and look at the
stuff as you would
just in a normal debugger.
So you're not actually
breaking execution,
but at least you have a
familiar interface into that.
And they've recently
added a new feature--
I think it's in the web UI, we
haven't added it the IDE yet--
which is called like
dynamic log points.
So how many times
you had like, where
you want to know
more information,
because something is
going wrong in production,
and you're like,
oh, jeez, I wish
I had added that log statement.
And then you go, you
add the log statement.
You rebuild.
Whatever-- you redeploy.
Hours go by.
And then you see the log,
and you're like, oh, wow.
I wish I had even more log info.
And then you do
that again, right?
With dynamic logs,
you actually can set--
at a point in the code that's in
production-- on a source line,
and say like, I want to
print this information--
these variables.
And it actually sets
that dynamically--
like in the bytecode.
So without having to
redeploy or anything,
you actually can set a
logging statement in there,
and you'll start seeing
the logging statements
as they're hit.
So that's like a really powerful
feature to sort figure out
what's going on production,
saving you probably
like hours or days
of redeploying
with more logs and more
logs and more logs.
So that's a really cool feature.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
As a Gopher, that
makes me super jealous.
That's going to be super quick.
MARK MANDEL: One day.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: One day.
MARK MANDEL: One day
you guys will get there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Soon.
MARK MANDEL: So I feel like we
should definitely take a stab,
or take a look at the
elephant in the room.
Java 8-- I believe that's--
what state is that in?
How's that going?
RAJEEV DAYAL: Java 8--
that's a good question.
That's a very good question.
So Java 8, actually, works
quite well, on App Engine Flex.
MARK MANDEL: Good.
RAJEEV DAYAL: If you have the
App Engine Flex environment,
we have supported
run times for Java 8
or Open JDK 8, plus Jetty
9, or just Open JDK 8.
And obviously, you're like,
what are you doing on standard?
Why isn't it there?
And you're right.
Well, that's actually
in the pipeline.
We can't promise
an exact date, yet.
But it's actively
being worked on.
And you know, it's
looking very promising.
So this is something
that's top of mind for us.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I just wanted to
add one funny thing.
When you said the
elephant in the room,
I thought about Hadoop.
But anyway--
MARK MANDEL: Different elephant.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
RAJEEV DAYAL: There's
a lot of elephants.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So I guess we're
kind of running out of time.
But is there any other topic
that you'd like to discuss--
something that we
might have missed--
Ray?
RAY TSANG: No, I
think I'm OK here.
But, oh, one thing
Francesc when are
you going to try to Java again?
I'm just wondering.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: When it
has support for Go routines.
You can call them Java
routines if you want to.
MARK MANDEL: You
can have Go routines
in alternative JVM languages.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: In
alternative lang.
Actually, I'm thinking
about learning Closure.
So, Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, that's nice.
RAY TSANG: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
like Java, just better.
Just kidding.
I am not a troll.
RAJEEV DAYAL: Yeah,
we're basically
going to keep investing
in Java as much as we can
until you switch over to Java.
So you know, we're
full steam ahead.
We're going to
get you off of Go.
MARK MANDEL: You know what?
That's an incentive for
you never to touch Java--
RAJEEV DAYAL: Right.
MARK MANDEL: --so that it
always gets better and better.
RAJEEV DAYAL: We're going to
keep working hard over here.
Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
am an important part
of the Java community
by not being part of it.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Exactly.
What about you Rajeev?
Is there any topic
that you'd like to--
RAJEEV DAYAL: No, I think we
covered everything pretty well.
This was great.
I guess all I would add
to it is that, yeah, we're
really serious about Java.
And we're putting a lot of
resources and investment
behind it, because
there's just so
much we can do to make it better
for Java developers on GCP.
There's just tons we can do.
So we're putting a lot
of attention there.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
And I know either
one or both of you--
are going to be at particular
events coming up as well?
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
So I do try to go to plenty of
Java related events and Java
user groups.
So I'm going to be traveling
quite a bit around.
One of the first
stops is going to be
JFocus in Sweden in February.
So I'm looking forward to that.
And if you do see me on the
road, or if you want to chat,
I would love to learn
about your experiences
and how you want
to use the platform
and provide any of
the feedback to us.
I'd love to get it back
to the engineering teams,
as well, to make our experience
better, and so that developers
will love to use.
MARK MANDEL: And
right after that, I
think we're going
to meet at FOSDEM.
RAY TSANG: Yeah, I will see
you at FOSDEM No, actually,
FOSDEM comes before that.
So I'm going to be in
FOSDEM for the weekend,
and then go straight to
Sweden right after that.
And there is also the Devoxx US.
That's going to be their first
Devoxx in the United States.
So I'm going to be there
with many, many other people,
as well, including
Guillaume Laforge and many
of the engineers.
We're going to be there.
So I'm looking forward to
meeting everyone in Devoxx US,
too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, to both of you, thank
you so much for joining us.
It has been a pleasure and a
delight talking to both of you.
RAY TSANG: Thank you.
My pleasure.
RAJEEV DAYAL: This was great.
Thanks so much.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So thanks
again to Ray and Rajeev
for taking the time and making
me discover that, actually,
Java is a very
interesting language
with a vibrant community.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah-- no, it
was a really good interview.
Obviously, Java is very
much alive and well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, that's for sure.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I used to use the JVM a lot.
So it's a warm spot
in my heart for it.
And so it's great to see all
the stuff that's going on there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No, I
like to joke about it.
But I know it is a very
interesting language.
Because, you know,
there's basically
half of the internet
that is built on it.
So it's good to have it, and
have a good place to run it,
like Google Cloud Platform.
Anyway I think it's time to go
with our question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: So we had a really
interesting question this week,
I think, in terms of say you
have a whole bunch of data
on Amazon S3, for example.
And you wanted to transfer
data to Google Cloud Storage.
Is there an easy
way of doing that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very
interesting question.
But I actually have a
pre-question for that,
which is--
do you know what S3 stands for?
MARK MANDEL: I do not
know what S3 stands for.
What does S3 stand for?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm almost sure
it's Simple Storage Surface,
but I am not completely sure.
But I think so.
It's kind of a cool name.
But, yeah, everybody
calls it S3.
And then it's like, what?
Anyway, how do you
transform it from AWS S3?
How do you move that data
to Google Cloud Storage?
I actually do not know.
MARK MANDEL: So
it is interesting.
So we do have a GSUtil
command line tool
for working with cloud storage.
You can use the GSUtil utility--
that sounds redundant--
the GSUtil tool
to work with Amazon
S3 buckets as well.
However, probably the most
efficient way of doing things
is we do have this thing
called a Cloud Storage Transfer
Service, which is specifically
set up for transferring data
from one cloud storage
provider to another,
which is kind of cool.
Obviously, you're going
to have network costs
for moving from one to the
other, so keep that in mind.
But you're able to set it up so
that you have basically sources
and sinks.
So like, where do you
want it to go from?
Where do you want it to go to?
And then you can
kind of set it up
to happen like periodically,
or maybe just once off.
There's a programmatic
interface.
You can go through
the console UI,
and there's a series
of REST APIs as well.
So you can really kind
of pick and choose
how you want it to work.
But it is a nice and easy way
of just transferring that data
across, if you need to do
that between different cloud
providers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
That sounds,
indeed, very useful.
I don't know how often
those kind of thing
are needed to be
done, but if you're
thinking about starting to
try Google Cloud Platform,
and it's like you need to
pass all your data around,
it's probably the
best way to do it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And I think it's kind of cool.
It's one of those things that
you really need it when you
need, but if you don't
need it then you don't.
It's one or the other.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: But if
you don't know it
exists, then it could be really
painful to pull everything
down, say, locally--
like via GSUtil--
and then push it
back up again into the cloud.
Whereas you'd much rather
run it over the big fat pipes
that usually run between
all the big datacenters.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And if
you need to do syncing in
between AWS and GCP,
I think that there
is a thing that I
should mention--
because it's tool written
in Go, and it's open source.
It's called Mineo.
And they're really cool,
because they're written in Go.
So of course, it's a cool tool.
But check it out.
It actually supports a bunch
of different assorted services
from different clouds.
So there's--
MARK MANDEL: Interesting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --S3, but also
there's Google Cloud Storage.
They have their
own Mineo server.
It also supports
OpenStack Swift.
So it's definitely worth
having a look if what you need
is a little bit more complex
than just passing from one side
to the other ones.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, Francesc, before
we run off today,
I think we should
remind people how
to get in contact with us,
so they can send us emails,
and cool things the weeks,
and questions of the week,
and all sorts of
other good stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes, because we
haven't done that yet in 2017.
So you say the things,
I say the places?
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Or whatever.
MARK MANDEL: So
we'll start with--
OK, if they want to go to our
domain name, where can they go?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
is gcppodcast.com,
or cloud.google.com/podcast.
MARK MANDEL: If they
want to email us,
where should they do that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: They
should send an email
to hello@gcppodcast.com.
MARK MANDEL: If they want
to find us on Reddit?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It is r/gcppodcast.
MARK MANDEL: If they want
to find us on Google+
FRANCESC CAMPOY: +Gcppodcast.
MARK MANDEL: And if they
want to find us on Twitter?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: @Gcppodcast.
MARK MANDEL: And
last but not least--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I think that
there's a theme going on.
MARK MANDEL: There's a
theme-- definitely a theme.
And finally, if they
want to find us on Slack,
where can they find us?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is the hard one.
On Slack, there's a
podcast channel inside
of the Google Cloud
Platform community
that you can join
by going somewhere?
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
Bit.ly/gcp-slack.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
We'll have all of those, just
in case people are wondering.
They're all in the page, anyway.
So just go check it
out at gcppodcast.com.
OK.
So before we go, I
guess it's time to ask--
where are you going
to be next week?
Actually, where are you now?
You you're in San Francisco.
I'm in Barcelona.
What are your plans afterwards?
MARK MANDEL: So I'll be at GDC--
the Game Developer Conference--
here in San Francisco.
We're sponsoring a bunch
of events going on.
So we are sponsoring
Women in Games.
If anyone is going to be at
that party, we'll be there.
We're sponsoring Blacks
in Games as well.
So if anyone is going to
be there, come say hello.
We'll be around.
I think if you're
looking for us,
we'll definitely be hanging
out by the Improbable booth,
because they're a
partner of ours.
And we have a
developer day-- there
is Google Developer
day on Tuesday,
and a sponsored session.
I'll be there talking
about basically running
dedicated game servers
in the cloud, mainly
on Kubernetes, actually--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: --both
in my lightning talk
and in our sponsored session
on Wednesday morning as well.
And then there will be Next.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
Cloud Next.
That's going to be fun.
That sounds like a lot of
things going on for you.
But it sounds fun.
Lots of parties.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's all around GDC.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
MARK MANDEL: GDC is
going to be crazy.
And I know you're up
to a bunch of stuff
while you're wandering
around Europe.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
I'm actually kind of doing
a European tour, because you
know I like the cold weather.
I'm currently in Barcelona,
because I will be speaking
at the Go meetup on Thursday--
so tomorrow.
And then, the week after
that I will be in Paris,
where I'm trying to
organize, also, a meetup.
But it's not completely sure.
But that weekend we'll be
in FOSDEM, in Brussels.
And we have a Go dev room.
So if you're
around, come say hi.
I think we still have a
place for lightning talks.
So if there's anyone
around there visiting,
and they want to give a
lightning talk about Go,
let me know.
And after that I'll be
coming back for GoSF.
We're going to celebrate
that Go 1.8 is coming out.
And the week after
that, GopherCon India--
so yeah, traveling a little
bit around the world.
And that is before Cloud Next.
So it's kind of crazy.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And you're presenting
at Cloud Next as well?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes, I am
presenting at Cloud Next.
I'm going to be talking
about Google Cloud Endpoints.
MARK MANDEL: Very cool.
I'll be onstage as well,
talking with our gaming
partner, Improbable,
about massively
large persistent online worlds.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
sounds very interesting.
That sounds kind of a
little bit like Pokemon
Go-- massively online worlds.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
This is more in the
MMO kind of realm--
very large online simulations.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
sounds pretty cool.
MARK MANDEL: It's very
interesting stuff, actually.
It is pretty cool.
Awesome.
Well, Francesc, thanks so
much for joining me yet
again this week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank
you so much, Mark,
for waking up so early.
And thank you all for listening.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And talk to you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
s